hier soir saint quentin en yvelines a
rendu hommage à ces entreprises plus de
600 personnes étaient réunies à bouygues
challenger à guyancourt pour la deuxième
grande soirée des entrepreneurs on leur
donne plein d'idées ce soir sur des
méthodes innovation comment utiliser
certains crédits de recherche se
comprendre des techniques d'innovations
cette culture qui augmentent et qui va
avantager leurs concurrents s'ils ne
s'approprie pas cette culture
d'innovation donc c'est pour les
stimuler ce soir les poussées et faire
bouger pour qu'ils aillent encore plus
loin dans l'innovation plus vite qui
s'accompagne du travail entre eux ainsi
vite pressé tout seul non c'est les
apprend aussi être avec les petits et
moyens les gros il doit échanger des
techniques d'aidé des stratégies des
moyens aussi un des objectifs mêmes et
pour l'occasion un concours était
organisé avec trois catégories grands
groupes d'allant et pme essais et
innovent qui a remporté le prix dans
cette catégorie l'entreprise a présenté
l'étude watch une montre qui garantit la
sécurité des personnes atteintes
d'alzheimer
les tig watch est un projet très
intéressant actuelle notamment pour
sécuriser les malades d'alzheimer
donc c'est un projet innovant avec ce
qu'on appelle de l'internet par l'objet
d'objets connectés
c'est la première fois qu'on communique
au niveau du projet il y aura des
prochaines fois certainement les deux
victoires j'espère on espère donc oui
c'est un projet qui est intéressant et
qui touche tout le monde
pari réussi pour saint quentin en
yvelines qui ambitionne toujours de
devenir la silicon valley française